Hey guys, i'm Nate and today we are making fully functional metal ninja throwing stars
There is a link to a PDF to download this template for throwing stars of course you can go with other designs
But I like this one so I'm gonna be using it
I have this piece of 16 gauge steel
Which costs less than $7 and has enough metal in it to make a bunch of throwing stars to make these ninja stars...
we'll be using a hacksaw a drill with a few different bit sizes a
Metal file and a small belt sander to help myself be able to drill through the steel
I also have this nice little punch
when you push it down into the steel plate it compresses a spring up to a certain point and then
Slams down onto it using the harden tip to make a mark in the steel that really helps you aim your drill bit right where
You want it to go we have a variety of sizes. Let's start by making this medium small throwing star
We do want to glue this piece of paper down on to our plate of Steel
We're going to be using some spray glue, but you could also use a glue stick or just some Elmer's glue
We now want to use our hacksaw to cut this piece of steel out from the rest of the plate
We need to drill nine holes into this ninja star eight going around the outside and one in the middle
Let's start by taking our punch and marking into the steel the very center of each of those nine holes
Now that we've marked the nine spots that we need to drill
We'll use our smallest drill bit to drill pilot holes through each of those wider drill bits often
Have a hard time drilling into a flat piece of steel so drilling a pilot hole can really help the drill bit start cutting where
it needs to
With all nine holes drilled it's time to move back to the bench vise and hacksaw
One of our eight points is now cut out let's go all the way around and do that for the rest of them
Once we have our ninja star down to this point we want to remove any
Excess bit of the metal that still has the white paper attached to it
We're trying to get our profile to match the black lines pretty closely
For this we can either use a metal file, or a small belt sander
I've got this one inch belt sander and
Using that tends to heat up the steel really quickly so I've got a bowl of water that I can use to cool it down
So it doesn't burn my fingers while I finish sanding it
You've now got all of the edges cut down to where we want to so at this point
We can remove the paper with some fine grit sandpaper, and then start doing some cleaning up and maybe a little bit of decorating
Now let's use that sandpaper and our rounded metal file to just clean up some of the edges
Especially the inside of this throwing star has a very jagged edge, and we don't want to cut ourselves on that
Our ninja star is getting really close to being ready to use
But I think we need to add a tapered edge on both sides of each of our points once again
We could be using our file for this. I prefer to use the 1 inch belt sander
At this point with the edges added on if you like the all-metal look you could just say you're done right here
But I think that this is a ninja tool, and we should make it a little bit more stealth
Let's take some black paint and see if we can't add on that black surface to our whole star
Our ninja star is now painted black and it's looking very stealthy
But I think I want to sand off the paint on all the edges, so we just have that little gleam of metal
Our ninja throwing star is now complete and just to see how it would go
I also made one of the larger and smaller sizes
Let's take these bad boys outside and see how they do against some targets first up is an extremely easy target
It's just a block of styrofoam the ninja stars should stick into it really easily
Not bad with the small one
I'm a little concerned about how well it will stick into things because it doesn't have much weight behind it
But of course on styrofoam even it does a great job
Today we learned that I am NOT a ninja
Our little one doesn't really seem to have enough mass to penetrate this particle board
But the medium and the large ones seem to do pretty well
Right in between from 15 feet away
The logs are like pressed up against each other and I managed to thread the needle
And get the throwing star in between two of them
Because that's how good of a shot. I am I couldn't do it on purpose if I tried 100 times but
That's a worse way of throwing them
Guys we've still got more for you see that little box up at the top will transport you directly to our last video go check
It out if you click the box down at the bottom
It'll show you YouTube thinks you should be watching next this bomb here in the middle will subscribe you to our channel
So you'll never miss out on a video again
Don't forget to ring that Bell and we'll see you the next one talk to you then